it's just a rash what went into making
the world's worst heroes look this good
the suicide squad is populated with
quite the cast of colorful and off-beat
villains plenty of these characters look
far from ordinary so of course there was
heavy makeup and prosthetics that were
needed to complete their outlandish
looks let's look at the painful
prosthetics and wacky costumes the stars
of the suicide squad had to endure while
filming we do
before margot robbie would even sit down
in the makeup chair the makeup artists
would have to think out how she would
look for the day of shooting including
the dirt blood rain and explosions her
character would encounter alongside her
bleached white skin and tattoos on
average it would take two hours a day to
complete robbie's transformation with
the makeup also having to correspond
with her costume i'm a princess
getting margo robbie's harley quinn
makeup off also proved to be a challenge
for the makeup department and the
actress which led to them integrating
unconventional methods and just a simple
washcloth wasn't going to do
they set up a pop-up tent inside an
abandoned building brought in a kiddie
pool and hosed the makeup off with
hudson sprayers
i love the rain while sylvester stallone
may have provided his vocals to the role
of king shark it was steva g a personal
friend of james gunn who was the
stand-in for the giant walking talking
shark aji's on-set costume wasn't
exactly the most comfortable thing to
wear aji's costume was equipped with a
giant metal wire frame hat to serve as
the shark head while a rubber grey suit
would be worn as a stand-in for the body
aji said that his initial suit weighed
around 40 pounds and was made of
styrofoam and the first day of wearing
it was an exhausting experience
i know friends
expressed that the makeup process for
her to play the alien mongal was far
from easy in fact ing's makeup routine
initially took four hours before being
narrowed down to three king revealed
that the makeup crew applied sealant on
her as they didn't want her orange
makeup to stick to chairs removing the
makeup was an even lengthier process
that even led the makeup artists to
panic from rubbing alcohol to chemicals
to even having ing going into a sauna to
sweat the makeup off
one of the strangest yet most memorable
moments in the suicide squad was polka
dot man's polka dot rash david
dismulchen had always been a fan of
creature makeup growing up and had even
considered becoming a makeup artist
before ultimately becoming an actor so
he was eager to get on the makeup chair
while cgi was certainly on the table for
the character's rainbow cysts gunn opted
to go the practical route two different
makeup artists applied to smulchin's
makeup that is latex and wires and
lights i mean my face really would light
up and i looked like a walking christmas
tree version of the elephant man at
points
it's happening to his face again
the most noticeable thing about peter
capaldi's squad getup is the wires and
electronics protruding from his bald
head capaldi wasn't actually wearing a
bald cap for the film he actually did
shave his head for the heavy prosthetics
work gunn revealed that the prosthetics
work did take a little bit of reworking
to perfect it but was more than thrilled
with the
results hand over the drive while margot
robbie's harley quinn still looks very
similar to how she was depicted in birds
of prey and the first suicide squad
there was some changes done in the
makeup department fans weren't entirely
too crazy about some of harley quinn's
tattoos in her first live-action
appearance and evidently neither were
robbie and director james gunn who
particularly disliked a certain one that
made her feel simply just uncomfortable
and wasn't true to the spirit of the
character so the decision was eventually
made to remove the rotten tattoo from
quinn's face
pete davidson is mainly known for his
work in comedy such as saturday night
live and the king of staten island but
the comedian found himself in unfamiliar
territory when he was cast as blackguard
despite his excitement and enjoyment of
being on set davidson said that his big
bulky costume was quite uncomfortable on
top of his costume already being
strapped to the brim with glocks i've
never been excited for a fitting before
sean gunn who's actually director james
gunn's real-life brother is no stranger
to playing critter-like characters in
his brother's films he had to perform in
a motion capture suit to take on the
role of the feral fan favorite where i
had all the
balls and lights and colors gunn was
actually not the most comfortable in his
suit but what made it even weirder was
the fact that he was actually made to
lick the glass window during a
particular scene and
they were really capturing everything i
did harley's initial leather jacket
outfit actually took some planning to
bring to life james gunn revealed that
he took his sweet time in deciding what
the back of harley's red and black
leather jacket should say with the final
three slogans world's greatest grandpa
clown af and live fast die clown with
the latter ultimately being the winner
the leather jacket was also quite heavy
for robbie which at times made it
awkward for robbie to perform her action
sequences robbie went on to express just
how exhausted she was after filming in
the heavy leather there are explosions
and guns firing and even though they're
blanks your body starts reacting as if
it's real your adrenaline is through the
roof sorry i'm late let's go number two
what makes bloodsport's costume so
unique in the film is that it's
technologically designed only for his
character's access but that wasn't
exactly the case for idris elba elba
revealed that he told james gunn that
the suit felt uncomfortable at first
which led gunn and elba to include that
as part of the character's personality
before becoming an actor michael rooker
was a lifeguard for three years on a
beach in chicago but that kind of
experience didn't prepare rooker for
having to swim in his savant outfit and
wig it was interesting that physicality
was really the biggest kind of
physicality thing that was the most
challenging for me in this movie
john cena's peacemaker getup is
certainly goofy but not out of place in
james gunn's supervillain bonanza from
the silver toilet bowl like helmet he
wears to the tight red shirt one would
think that cena would be quite
uncomfortable in his super suit but over
the course of filming the suicide squad
as well as filming the peacemaker
spin-off series cena seemed to have
grown a fondness to his suit even
wearing it on talk shows to take naps
and he even wore it to the red carpet
i've learned that if you just keep the
costume on they don't ask for it back
the only downside to the suit according
to cena's co-star flula borg his cast
mates were constantly using his shiny
helmet to check their teeth um i am a
horrible superhero
joel kinnaman's rick flagg didn't fully
resemble his comic book counterpart in
the first film so when it came time for
the standalone sequel kinnaman and james
gunn wanted to make some changes
apparently it was kiniman himself who
really pushed hard for rick flagg to
wear the flashy yellow shirt and gun
suspenders which resemble the
character's attire in the dc comics
according to kineman james always wanted
to honor the original comic he really
owns that world it was a really good
plan too flulaborg was excited to
finally try out his javelin outfit but
the costume crew were extremely
secretive about it putting on the suit
was like an out of body experience for
borg i felt like i was walking around
with my shoulders back more and standing
taller i became an instant
because javelin is one american women
all love accents there was so much
effort put into making the costumes and
makeup of james gunns the suicide squad
look as vibrant as they did daniella
melchior even had to endure one of the
rat actors marking his territory by
peeing on her shoulder what was your
favorite costume from the suicide squad
you